i went to draymond's wedding like they  just beat us in the finals you know it  was kind of tough seeing all the team  there but like draymond is a great  friend of mine and i felt honored that  he wanted me to be at that special day  okay but also the photo y'all all took  so good obviously you're out the wedding  but like what happens they're taking the  photos and then are they just like jason  so i seen the photo booth and it was a  long line and braun and steph and  draymond they took a picture they all  got four rings i was walking past and  rich rich poe was right there and he  grabbed me he like yo take this picture  with us i wasn't gonna say no we got in  the picture we took like a normal one  and then draymond was like man it's my  wedding we got turned up so we just  start dancing that's when like you have  to get friends oh for sure yeah